final ask to be challenged that is the
Abby Lee Miller that millions of
Americans got to know on the show Dance
Moms today it was a much more subdued
and emotional Abby who appeared in
federal court for sentencing arriving
with her attorney Abby Lee kept a
composed smile on her face as she
entered a Pittsburgh courthouse the
Dance Moms star is facing up to two and
a half years behind bars after pleading
guilty to fraud charges last June
prosecutors claim Abby Lee hit seven
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars in income after filing for
bankruptcy in an emotional et interview
back in March she confessed that the
thought of prison scared her what do you
fear most about being sentenced on fraud
charges I just don't want to fight
anymore I don't want to do it are you
prepared to spend time in prison yeah
if Abby Lee goes to prison one of her
concerns will be whether the prison food
fits her restricted diet just 17 days
ago we were with Abby as she had gastric
sleeve surgery she broke down just
before the surgery I'm an only child I'm
not married I don't have any kids
there's nobody freaking out if something
happens to me Abby Lee is hoping for
leniency is this a fair punishment
though if you do have to spend time in
prison well like I teach my kids life is
not fair
you